ding struck back after a devastating and
ear-reddening Mistake by Jan napanishi
allowed a brilliant Rook Sacrifice by
ding Loren with the match at 2-1 in
nepo's favorite ding opened the game
with 1c4 and rolled into the English
Four Knights variation ding sacrificed a
pawn for a strong Center early but the
game remained nearly balanced until nepo
moved his Knight to D4 whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa it's hanging right no way ding
with his hands shaking in disbelief
sacrificed his Rook attaining a
monstrously strong Knight and mobilizing
his powerful Central Pawns
we saw it on the screen double
exclamation mark move a winning
brilliant move Look his hand was shaking
he almost did you see how he took the
Knight his hand was shaking he almost
dropped the Rook there he's on fire
right now he's back in the zone he's
playing every move instantly the
position rapidly deteriorated for nepo
and in a hopeless position with ding's
epon ready to promote nepo resigned with
the match now at 2-2 the momentum is
with ding and that's how